right still ahead someone may soon  become a multi-millionaire the  mega millions jackpot is now at 468  million dollars the jackpot  has been climbing actually since  february so if you want to play  the closest place to buy a ticket just  over the california state line near prim  or you can head over to  bullhead city in arizona the next  drawing is at eight o'clock tomorrow  night  [Music]  ted remember when we used to send you to  one of the the bordering cities and he  i was reading your mind right and you'd  be like hey here's five dollars we'd get  like a whole pool together  how was your jackpot mule didn't realize  that  yeah you were like ted you're do you  cover the story right well here's  all our money you're lucky i came back  it was the honor system  yeah it really never won so right that's  true  i literally had a packet of money yeah  holding down there and got all the  tickets and we never won